please welcome sarah zimmerman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been doing this a long time i think
you're the first guest to walk out with
a cell phone first guest i'm looking for
something for you that i just realized
would be funny okay all right
okay um
so i did like a psa for aids a while ago
right not for aids but you know what i
mean
and um to help fight aids yeah so my dad
saw it
and i got this email from him and i know
he means that he's proud but it was just
really funny the way it came out or
something let's take a look here hold on
let's see right there this is from your
dad about your aides
wonderful
oh god
so he i know what he's trying to say as
do i yeah it was heartwarming it was
heartwarming but it didn't come out
right so aids wonderful yeah so that on
a pillow yeah um
are you yeah go on you want to do
something else with the phone i do i i
okay i came up with a craft
that you can do with the phone okay
anyone can do it
and uh let's see it would take like
either one of you can do it get like
turn to your head to the side okay like
this like this and then just let your
mouth be
loose and natural and maybe put but put
your lips together
and put your tongue out just a tiny bit
well a little more tongue
okay
okay
wow
[Applause]
i really wish you still had the beard
[Applause]
yeah your your lips are very we're not
airing this now
this is going into a time capsule this
one's a little bad
it's what it's a mouth
you're right do you realize just by
doing that on television right now how
many young people will be doing that i
think it's good i think it's good to get
used to the lady parts and not make them
shame-filled things and
you know oh another idea for girls like
teenagers girl teenagers call your
girlfriends [ __ ]
i think that's like like instead of bro
because it sounds like you're putting
them down but it's it's just real
and uh it's like [ __ ] come on let's
go we're going to the movies you know
it's like a fun humored
all right so it's a way to empower women
you think that empowers women i just
think being comfortable and vocal about
your body is just fine i think a lot of
people agree with you i do not
i am uptight and ashamed of my body yeah
you have an app is this correct you have
an app that's coming out this week i do
i i don't know exactly when it's
sometime this week if you follow me on
twitter i'll say when it comes out it's
called uncle sarah and it's for babies
and toddlers
and um it's like
i know that's where the money is
it's not segue from this but um well
it's actually kind of nice actually
yeah oh yeah babies come from the
beautiful vagina
and iphone
you can just shoot another guest no
i like that i really do like this i'm
just this is therapy for me this is good
yeah it's yeah you're very you're
uptight irish like just say vagina no i
won't kill it i won't vagina no
no
vagina come on
who told you to sing it
jesus there's no better time let's talk
about wreck it ralph congratulations
number one movie this weekend no is that
good number one
i like the way you did that and then is
this right the director
uh one of the reasons that he asked you
to come in for this role was because he
was such a big fan of your book the bed
wetter yeah i didn't realize that until
we started doing press and the director
rich moore who's so great i guess he he
mentioned that he had read my book and
he kind of started basing this character
vanellope on young me and it i didn't
realize that but it i was so connected
to her it made sense you know because
it's she's this glitch she's she's in a
racing game called sugar rush and they
won't let her race because she's a
glitch
and all the characters are from video
games yeah it's it's video it's an
arcade after dark and all the video
games come to life
and um and i understand that you know
like the lesson is kind of that glitch
you have that that thing that makes you
that you think you'll be ashamed of for
your whole life you know your your
downfall if you let it can be your
superpower you know it can can end up
being an asset and i felt that way you
know i was a bedwetter
you know my book was called the
bedwetter and i was a bedwetter well
into my teens and i had to go to sleep
away camp and i had so much humiliation
that for me
doing stand-up was just not at all
daunting because the idea of bombing in
front of strangers was nothing compared
to wetting your bed every night at sleep
away camp can yeah but you know when
you're a bed wetter conan
i realize there's only one group of
people you can feel better than
um bed
squeeze that i squeeze
it just occurred to me that you're here
to promote a disney movie
[Applause]
everything with the ah the iphone and
the i love it at disney i know but at
disney right now they're watching and
their heads are blowing up i know soon
stop her
wait a minute let's watch a little more
uh
this is a doll this is a sign that
you've really made it there's a
vanellope
doll yes that uh is this is fantastic
she talks yeah you press her throat
which is weird
he's got a date with destiny
wow cute
i'm not a glitch taffeta i've got
pixlexia
let's call clowns what they really are
smiling murderers wait a minute
i don't think that's true i have oral
herpes
[Laughter]
well a fine disney product
available in store just in time for
christmas not only are you banned from
disney world now but we are too advanced
yeah
wreck it ralph we have a clip uh
anything you need to tell us about this
clip this is an actual real clip
and
that never happens on this show it's
when ralph of wreck-it ralph fame john c
riley who's brings so much
warmth okay i'm sorry uh when
he meets my character vanellope for the
first time let's take a look
hey
are you a hobo
no i'm not a hobo but i am busy okay so
you go go home what's that didn't hear
you your breath is so bad it made my
ears numb listen i try to be nice
you're mimicking
that is rude and this conversation is
over
i wouldn't grab that branch if i were
you i'm from the candy tree departments
i know
[Music]
[Applause]
in theaters now
and you got to get this the complete
series of the sarah silverman program is
now available on dvd and this is a very
good thing to have sarah silverman
thrilled you're here we'll be right back
brian austin green
you